souvenez vous de vos 4500 dernière
conversation téléphonique
je vais prendre un ciseau je vais les
découper je vais les mettre bout à bout
et en plus des conversations avec mon
avocat c'est qu'une justice monsieur
bull l affaire des écoutes peut poser
beaucoup de questions autant sur le fond
que la forme mais si on se penche un peu
plus sur l'aspect déontologique de cette
affaire on se rend compte qu une part
d'ombré subsistent nicolas sarkozy et
son avocat ont été mis sur écoute
le premier président de la cinquième
république à avoir été condamnés à de la
prison ferme dénonçant l'espionnage de
ses conversations avec son avocat pour
rappel le secret professionnel est
absolue est il limité mais où s'arrête
il est est ce qu'il est bafouée avec les
mises sur écoute on tente d'y répondre
dans facture les interceptions de
communications existe depuis aussi
longtemps que le téléphone lui-même soit
mais ce n'est qu'en 1991 que son
utilisation devient formellement encadré
avec la loi relative au secret des
correspondances émises par la voie des
communications électroniques en 2014
d'après un rapport de la commission
nationale de contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité
58% des motifs des coudes porté sur la
criminalité organisée
ces écoutes au fil du temps depuis 1991
elles n'ont cessé d'être d'être en cas d
encadrer ray encadrée par des lois par
des parts des décisions de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme par de
la jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
elles doivent être demandées par des
magistrats en plus il faut justifier de
ses de ces interceptions
il faut justifier de l'infraction que
l'on est en train de poursuivre il faut
noter dans le temps quand est-ce qu'elle
commence quand est ce qu'elle s'arrête
il ya le verrou du juge de la liberté et
de la détention notamment en ce qui
concerne les enquêtes préliminaires
jamais on n'a été aussi loin dans la
défense des justiciables en matière
d'écouté alors il faut pas confondre les
écoutes
voilà quand il s'agit de la délinquance
organisée ou de délinquance tout
simplement et puis le cas particulier
des avocats écouté un avocat écouter des
conversations entre
quand un client c'est peut-être pas tout
à fait la même chose qu'eux qui écoute
et de trafiquants de drogue en train de
de préparer un go fast
mais alors pourquoi la mise sur écoute
d'un échange entre un client et son
avocat diffèrent d'une tout autre
interception parce que justement les
échanges entre un avocat et son client
sont un sanctuaire puisque l'avocat est
soumis au secret professionnel
quand je crois qu'il ya pas un pénaliste
ou vos car d'ailleurs d'affaires et
cetera qui ne vous dira pas que la
question des écoutes ccc le poison c'est
un poison dans la relation entre avocats
et clients
indubitablement le secret professionnel
les protégés par le règlement intérieur
national de la profession d'avocat et
par le règlement intérieur du barreau de
paris
l'avocat est le confident nécessaire du
client le secret professionnel de
l'avocat et d'ordre public
il est général absolue et illimitée dans
le temps et couvre toutes les matières
et tous les supports
donc la conversation entre un avocat et
son client ne doit jamais être mises sur
écoute
sauf dans certains cas très particulier
alors évidemment il ya deux cas où le
secret c'est dans quelque sorte c'est
dans un conflit aux civils entre un
avocat et son client met en jeu la
responsabilité civile de l'avocat donc
là évidemment pour juger des faits il
faut bien ouvrir le secret le secret
professionnel pour vérifier cette
respect de l'engagement de cette
responsabilité civile et puis au pénal
mais au pénal pour ouvrir ce secret sa
crosse sacro saint secret professionnel
eh bien il faut avoir des indices que
l'avocat participent
à la commission d'une infraction sans
ces indices est bien n'est pas possible
de toucher de toucher au secret et
symonds n'étaient pas moins 10 il faut
encore respecter un cadre très strict
pour écouter un avocat et son client
la première c'est qu'il faut
impérativement informer le bâtonnier et
il est également interdit de
retranscrire la conversation entre un
avocat et une tierce personne
si cette conversation intervient dans le
cadre de sa défense
le secret professionnel reste tout de
même préservé pendant des échanges
quand on se sent loin d'un téléphone si
par exemple si moi je me rends dans le
cabinet de mon avocat et que je lui a
que je lui avoue un un crime atroce on
est seuls tous les deux personne
personne ne saura ne le sera jamais ne
le sera d'autant moins qu'il est
interdit de sonoriser un cabinet
d'avocats en revanche si je fais la même
confidences sur une ligne téléphonique
une ligne téléphonique écouter parce que
parallèlement me soupçonne d'avoir
commis une escroquerie par exemple est
bien là le secret professionnel vole en
éclat que c'est ce qui pose à un
problème est qui qui pose la question du
statut véritable de la confidence et
jusqu'où et protéger cette confidence
comme le rappelle cette proposition de
loi déposée le 15 septembre 2020 la
confidentialité des échanges n'est pas
un privilège d'avocats c'est un droit du
citoyen le secret professionnel est donc
d'ordre public et toute limitation doit
être strictement encadré
je crois que se pose plus profondément
et je dirais plus philosophiquement la
question de la confidence d'un client à
son avocat depuis sa prise de fonction
et comme il l'a rappelé sur france inter
j'ai assisté depuis 30 ans
un délitement du secret professionnel le
garde des sceaux eric dupond-moretti
compterait forme et le respect du secret
professionnel
il y as dont jetez y un problème
inhérent au secret professionnel des
avocats et je compte le revenu
eric dupond-moretti grand avocat
pénaliste est connu pour ses 145
acquittement a dévoilé les grandes
lignes de son projet de réforme de la
justice au point qui devrait s'intituler
loi pour la confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire
le garde des sceaux veut donc mieux
protéger le secret professionnel des
avocats en donnant accès aux
perquisitions de cabinet écoutes
téléphoniques les fadettes que si
l'avocat concerné est suspecté d'avoir
commis une infraction
ce ne seront plus simplement des indices
mais des infractions qui seront exigées
pour mettre un avocat sur écoute d'après
cette nouvelle réforme
[Musique]